[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey y'all happy Friday
hello oh shoot that's not oh shoot it's
the second time we've done this I'm not
robbed I've left the Third's it's a wish
that I were robbed I'm not rob mom's a
funny dude he's a good dude yeah that's
a good dude hey yeah I'm John Luke and
this is Ben hi we're playing at Monster
Hunter on our weekly monster hundred
Friday the third look it's fine don't
worry about it you're not gonna see him
anymore
perfect but you are gonna see our
session ID because we play Monster
Hunter with you guys so come on in we
got some fun all these events this week
Ben yeah they've finally put some real
hardcore stuff in there we got a
tempered hunt a temperate event quests
and I'm real nervous so please come in
and play with please save us really cool
hunts boy with us well guys great to see
you again good to see you too Kayla
fantastic av gamer GameSpot good to see
you appreciates I appreciate these
regulars we're starting to recognize in
the chat and in the session as well
that's really cool so it's a it's a good
time I like a lot of fun I like this so
how do we want to start this off cuz I
know we got we gotta get some cool in
here we don't want to go into the the
heavy stuff right away oh I want people
in here for that same so should I mean
there are there are a low-rank west
still because of course there are lower
angle yeah what do we got we could go
and just mess up some really cool Yakub
with that that's an old throwback that
is there again for some reason we could
we got that you've got the poison posse
oh that's gonna be a good time three
monsters okay this one that's the five
boys we got a Diablo so Ratheon they're
off a slippery snake boy and then this
is the one we're probably gonna build up
to gonna be a heck of a time tempered
that's all it's fun I'm gonna need to
change up my armor when I get to that so
we just had to late an airplane in the
background so everything's fine now but
yeah ooh adventure says hey guys hoping
to join the hunt absolutely dude get on
that session ID and yeah oh these are
the only one of these are in an arena -
well why don't we just do that uh yeah
cool bad let's warm up this is news we
gotta get people into this session ID so
I'm not gonna use a voucher on this
because I'm not excited about why yeah
you don't want to get some low rank you
know what gaku parts I'm not even gonna
eat on my way to this quest I'm gonna
just go damn forget about it
dude you're a baller you've helped are
you offering to come in you want to hunt
with us Oh what gamespot wants to hunt
oh my god mr. GameSpy mr. GameSpot
captain GameSpot themselves I'm into it
heard a lot about this game blazing this
game is amazing
okay I can't oh not dude you that is a
one-person quest hold on I think I
actually I set it up for one person so I
do this weird thing where if I play solo
I automatically set everything to one
because I want to like not have people
coming abandoned me but your hope I'll
post it up for real this time so I was
asking if we have any mods I assume you
mean like moderators in the chat uh yeah
typically in our live streams Ryan
around Schubert will be in there and Ben
when he saw on the stream yeah holy show
up in the chat as well always watching
forever and usually a is also kind of
watching as well so all right let's try
this again
there we go this this is this is what we
were looking for all right again I'm
bill I'm not gonna eat on this quest I'm
just gonna jump in and Damned all right
let's do it I'm ready I'm gonna stand by
for departure I'm gonna wait for you to
be ready to go yeah I'm ready let's do
it all right
I think we're good yep good yeah oh
you're not eating - aw critical opposite
ways that was really cool
you see that that's soul life all day
every day because I apparently the like
that one of the top stories on the the
reddit from Oscar hunter right now is
people who are griefing people who are
like you finish a fight and they will
just stun them so they can't get their
carves at the end of the the fight oh
that's really mean it's a real jerk move
don't do that people not well don't
worry we do not condone such heinous
actions you're not here on Monster
Hunter Fridays now Mondays you know I'm
gonna take I'm gonna take a second
healing thing though yeah all right away
we go
as dude so this should be real easy real
quick not really much to worry about
yeah you also left it open so but I
guess some people want to join ya jump
anything they can I imagine this will be
pretty quick though Who am I gonna jump
on first yeah who do we want to go for
uh you know let's leave oh there we go
right down on top of them
yo lure them to the middle Mon and I'm
on it hey you should come over here to
poke alright drop the rocks on me if you
got who I'm ready for okay
one of them's kind of kind of there yep
there it is done and come on come on get
that time and get that time you get one
of them we got we got the most important
one so drop those rocks material
well we do have so enjoined perfect I
like it so yeah again if you would like
to join our session the idea is right
underneath our our picture join up
hangout I'm about to get flashed again
got me - yike Rooney's join up hangout
we'll be doing all the the new event
quests leading up to that that double
tempered hunch
cowboy which may or may not actually
will find out I I have faith in us all
so if we have time today uh I would like
to make it a second shot at a black
Diablos oh yeah I know I'm down we got
we can get the run back yeah we could
retry and go for that one ah dang that
stupid flash I need like let's get them
focusing too much on the other boy yeah
I need to see that's that's the oh wait
hold on do we we finished the fight oh
it's already oh oh okay cool it's gonna
make sure I just want these parts
they're very important so I didn't
looked into it too much but I know
there's supposed to be like a a skill
that lets us so you can't get
interrupted while carving or something
like that no like helps her carve out
yeah I'm not sure what it's called say I
never really think about it don't
interrupt me don't even let me don't
under me don't me yes come on I don't
really need these parts but I want them
anyway cuz you know what maybe I don't
need this that badly I want it I want it
too but it's what it's all about
I'm just here for these sweet carbs man
nothing else
oh oh we all got knocked away
come on just give me in there so poke my
friends I guess
oh we got a great sword in here nice I
like it
LOV Phoenix he uh deep Phoenix has been
in before with us yeah oh it took too
long and now I can't get first of my
parts
this is already off to a great start
rardy we're already just doing a real
quick murder on on all these things this
is this is good this is the confidence
boost I need sure
don't be honest I actually haven't been
playing Monster Hunter very much this
week I kind of hit a point where the
streams are pretty much my my Monster
Hunter time that's that's that's fair I
feel like until like they put out even
like the the resets that we we do on
Fridays or maybe even when they get the
monsters rolling out again new monsters
in the events which also seem to phone a
Friday for the crossover things right
we've now we're in the point where we're
just monster hunting for the for for the
thrill of the hunt
exactly we're not trying to push to save
the environment or anything we're just
oh I forgot I have should just add okand
and sure you could my way all the way
there you go oh no I didn't mean to I
mean to hit you
apologize oh good the dragon eater will
be available in a minute
it's just what we needed jump off now so
you alright
kill yours good seal and thanks Rob and
bye take it easy have a good day oh do
my stretches that's exactly we're
warming up take all these cool things
sweet and the next quest uh-oh man Ben
you sure did track those monsters down
look okay I've if anyone needs to find
monsters inside of a pit I got you this
is your man I'm the one cuz I wanted to
jump off and definitely get the first
hit because I'm very excited get you a
man that can track monsters
do it it's what uh someone mom always
said to me yeah it's very important it's
it's a it's a it's a heck of a skill oh
I get a login bonus again what yep there
we go uh what was the next one
it's another low rank yeah but we got
people in now so we just get it out of
the way let's just keep goin hips that
gathering hub might join the quest
little light it's all good I'm just glad
that you're you're showing up that's all
that's all we need
that's what we're looking for man it
everything just looks better on on your
ps4 Pro there's more color yeah it's got
okay so I mean the HDR is not working
because this is a nature dere monitor
yeah or anything but um actually think
the HDR employee implementation and this
one's not that great in this game that's
fair
like the game hasn't very like washed
out look to it yeah and the HDR doesn't
really add much honestly so ah it's the
poison posse oh okay I'll ask you a
little closer here hope you don't mind
no no go for it get on in here I'm gonna
post this up when I see that you you get
inside of the area yep Here I am I'm
going stone is waving hello Aaron hello
alright it is posted now let's join a
quest I'm going to eat for this one
because I don't trust these monsters at
all now which camp did you pick I picked
the top one thank you mmm yeah so I can
use my voucher yeah I didn't either
what up Andrew how's it going this game
any good looks pretty pretty good and
fun to you oh yeah if it looks good and
fun to you you'll have a good time with
it
I guarantee it it's a great time there's
cats they give you food true look at
this yeah it's running around with their
boxes this one's got a hankerchief on
his back hopeful hopeful feline he
disappeared behind these boxes I'll
never see him again oh man just left me
I can't believe it there's another John
Luke in the chat whoa whoa it's John
whoa whoa I don't like this you said
it's like Highlander situation there
could only be one can only be one shoot
dude I've only met I want to say to
other John Luke's personally and both of
them were from South Africa Oh gotcha
that's I do you met another one today
are you from South Africa I'm gonna say
no based on the last name you're gonna
find out that it's one of the John
Luke's you've already met oh my god it'd
be good time tricky I'm sorry I didn't
mean to ignore you I just got really
excited but I see you and I'm happier
here hello tricky how are you doing
today looking good not much Ben think
about getting into this game it looks
gorgeous it is confirmed absolutely yeah
well also throw out there if if you're
if you're joining us for a hunt you
might need to mute your microphone
because sometimes sometimes I hear us Oh
microphones and I think I just heard I
think I just heard you do you want to
you can turn that off actually I would I
would go to your bangs my chat entirely
is it something have to do inside of the
I think you can just in the audio
settings there's a button there's a
button thing you can do
okay I'd maybe turn that off not that we
don't love mean hearing you guys we just
don't want the audio to get all weird
just go to just go to your yeah voice -
I love you guys I love you guys that
doesn't yeah uh should be should be good
yeah um I'm gonna grab some supplies cuz
I think I didn't or did I
I didn't
alright alright what we gonna fur first
well let's see here is anyone already
found it okay it looks like alright well
you guys are all not in the camp oh I
meant like the the physically top oh I I
thought meant like the top one on the
list I feel like a fool now because that
makes way more sense oh I'm going to
guess that maybe there's one of these
yeah they look like they're all going
after the PG PG right now I'm into it so
which actually if I jump down I should
be able to get to
we shouldn't be separated because we
don't want to make people fight
multiplayer leveled monsters but instead
no no no no no do you keep you keep you
might be fine but probably not the other
ones yeah alright I'm on my way let me
get my slide on alright
I'm not gonna get my slide on I'm gonna
run into a wall okay I think I think I'm
think I might be going the right way I'm
definitely going the right way okay yep
here we go
yep I'm on the right path to turn yeah
there we go
fatum there's our switch axe DOL over
here doing work already I'm gonna jump
right on his tail off the bat shagging
that honey little icons next to the
defense stats oh shoot message went away
icons next to the defense stats maybe
resistances I'm trying to think of where
where we might have seen them probably
when you had your thing pop-up probably
oh yeah the little icon means that those
are affected by our food oh there you go
oh you already got him yeah that was a
quick murder not surprised so on my end
I'm just walking and all the Senate cuts
to a cutscene of
oh no I'm dying which is nice that they
do that but I'm here to be here just in
time to get the carbs perfect whoo
hopefully uh okay good
certainly got a Jag receipt the Phoenix
get here faster than me I was like
further I ran past them you know those
are those shortcuts Sal all right I'm
already tracking something this way so
I'm gonna it's gonna be a wrath you know
Rathalos what is what is what are we
gonna pull what do we got I'm really
excited when these events are gonna be
all high ranked monsters Yeah right
because I really just don't have any
need for any of these low ranked parts
anymore yeah unless you wanted to like
maybe build up another weapon but yeah
that's about it
sweet made it live I'm glad you hear
Tethys I'm glad you were able to make it
to a live a live event live taping
here we are live monster honor Mondays
on Friday just let me let me hunt
everything all at once might confuse the
game and not let it know what I'm
actually wanting to track oh so I
believe they're up where are we going
after the Ratheon I'm not I'm not sure
they're both up right now from where I
am yeah
so also realize that I walked away from
all of you oh I see him the rafting is
near with a P Q P Q usually uh okay
chills out well I'm gonna go back and
down oh no he's moving again
dang Oh God classic way it's that boy
going Fe and maneuver where they don't
below here oh yeah they are I found him
Phantom awesome keep them there fight me
[Music]
I all right way more afraid of this
thing that I need to be I'm almost there
truthfully the it's a it's a low-rank
rathian so like you're probably fine I
still you know um yeah
multiplayer one though yeah be a little
bit tougher ah awesome I'm here finally
I get to fight a monster ah yes my
favorite part of the monster hunt when I
gets to fight the monster I want to do
that that that's actually my favorite
part that's it's so good it never gets
old
every time really it really doesn't I'm
gonna try to whack away at this tail
again
what my dude Oh much Doge very Wow
on twitch is asking you God of War
history of when John Luke oh that
actually is one of the ones I'm planning
on working on boom there you go look
forward to that in sometime next month
there you go got those hot exclusives
coming down the pipes we got got a war
history of us in the works in fact there
is a new history of coming up tomorrow
whoo-hah Rathalos is here in fact I
should double check after the stream
that that's all good to go
but yeah there there will be a new one
up tomorrow Oh tomorrow as soon as
tomorrow yeah not not they got knocked
out of work got Awards on tomorrow go
just a a history of is up tomorrow it's
actually made by our good friend Dave in
the UK all the way from the you all the
way from the UK look forward to that
oh that's not what I want to do I keep
my West oh the other boy showed up I'm
gonna grind my weapon out right here
right next to what we're fighting is a
mess yeah yeah I mean anytime a Ratheon
and a rathalos are involved and now it's
a it's sure to be a good time someone's
knocked down I can't tell it's absolute
pandemonium get out of here
sure yeah all they're doing the
runaround man is there such a thing as
shoutcasting Monster Hunter fights and
Rathalos is down here he comes throwing
a fireball will it hit will it lands no
it's a Miss looks like Phil's using the
Dukan of an odd choice doesn't really do
much damage oh and the Ratheon is down
this is sure to make the rathalos very
angry let's see if they can get the
carve I can't believe this this is real
dumb
I'm oh you guys are getting your carves
I'm just literally getting tossed around
thanks for distracting him I'm trying to
bring the guys forget about this yeah
there we go I mean I feel bad because
you guys were doing your thing but I got
I got my car I'm good you give him a
good flash give me dinner first I can't
deal with this I do have a flash
actually I'm starting to carry around
flash stuff too yeah oh no he's leaving
it's true canonic this is a cannon fight
and that the Rathalos is actually very
upset because we killed the the number
one ship for Rathalos so check out my
fanfiction account where I've written
many Monster Hunter fan fictions yeah
I'm more of a rathian Pooky Pooky Oh
chipper say they both understand the
ways
the poison stuff yeah it's all about the
tongue I can I was about to say I'm with
you on this and then you you made it all
too real now I don't know what to think
just keeping you on your toes
it's okay someone's got oh oh man you
know what I want to make a a rathalos
set just a have it for my mic my cosplay
you know just like the rathalos said oh
you know I actually like the beta set a
little better than the Alpha set the the
shorter yeah makes sense I'm into it a
little too spiny for me personally it's
very spining alright I got lost
that's fair apparently guys are right
below me but there's no way to get they
all figure there's some like weird
walkway is going on I'm moving around I
guarantee they're gonna run away to the
nest though well probably and it's gonna
happen as soon as you show up here oh
definitely no don't grab me
there we go now we got that tail oh you
got the tail off oh yeah oh I need to
get that tail
I haven't done like my special attack at
all what am i doing
going up bringing it down oh shoot man I
got boys you know I'm not gonna lie I'm
actually thinking a lot about monster
hunter monster ships now ooh it's really
it's a real weird place for me right now
and I don't know how to deal with it
like who everyone everyone's kind of
matchup you know yeah there's uh I don't
know about your gig auntie though it's
like a very aggressive lover yeah I'm
not all those spikes you know he's a
good spiky boy oh yeah gotta find an
equally spikey boy or someone with armor
that an equally spikey yessir to to
compliment exactly we should stop
talking yeah I'm gonna say that dude you
know what exists out there
oh yes that's the thing and people would
make impassioned arguments for any
monster with any other monsters what I'm
gonna do when I go back to my desk is
I'm gonna go pull up fanfiction.net is
that the one that everyone I believe so
I mean I wouldn't know not at all all
right one of my favorite Twitter
accounts is I think it's like fanfiction
dot
andum excerpts from fanfiction and uh
just like tweets it out it's already
good thanks now any contacts yeah it
never gets to not safe for work or
anything like that
I appreciate just just weird enough that
you're like oh that's hmm okay there I
was I done like a dumb google search and
I'd come up with AI you know what
sometimes when there's like a crossover
that someone does in a fanfiction that
you'd never think about and I had to
tweet it out when it happened because it
caught me so off guard and someone me
and the yeah he went he went oh I'm
faster I'll be easier
someone made a crossover with my
favorite adventure game grim
and undertale and I didn't that actually
wow you know what that actually makes a
lot of sense it makes sense but like I
never would have thought about no I
wouldn't have either but that actually
makes I wouldn't be like Oh Manny
Calavera yeah definitely hanging out
with with all those understands like
just yeah that's hmm Wow any weird stuff
I feel stupid for not actually thinking
about that right like that just seems so
obvious
alright uh looks like we got a barrel
I got a barrel um you guys down forget
teleport I want to I want to experience
walking through the forest as an actual
wait we're gonna wait for you guys to
show up I think cuz you think you're
just gonna do the murder right off the
bat probably so I come up over this hill
and just see a giant flaming explosion
rathalos parts flying everywhere
I feel bad for that boy yeah you guys
are almost year we could capture it you
know I could capture this I don't know
if these barrels are full of a captured
use I don't think the full capture juice
either
but definitely full of murder brand
murder juice and all right here we are
lets everyone pose up for a picture
it'll be a good time I'm gonna get Bray
trade photo no strike I could have just
had open the barrels well it's not dead
so I mean he's wanted if you want to a
capture you captured the tempered
monsters I've actually never tried that
I can't see why you wouldn't be able to
so I think the only thing you can't
capture is colored Elder Dragons
alright well they're dead we did it so
those are the easy ones and now we're
gonna get into that that how we're doing
the tough steps so the yeah the five
fibers of a high rank right yeah yeah oh
boy that's gonna be good I know I wonder
if it's just a high ranked quest though
because it's a bunch of low rank
monsters Oh someone got something you
did you got a plate oh nice uh no I'm
pretty sure they say anything above
anything ranked six are above is high
ranked monsters and I believe it was
like a rank six or seven I believe some
Rathalos material we ate I'll shoot I
sat down way far away from you I want to
I want to hang out with you I want to I
want to be right here here we go what's
up guys
chillin straight chillin don't at me I
like your hair
Thank You V Phoenix oh yeah I mean I
like your hair too Oh V Phoenix
yeah I was checking out every I like to
look at everyone's characters I've seen
enough of your character Sean those real
see them all the time before it's just
not there anymore so it's okay and one
day I just come home and I'm like your
fight you're fighting what the what are
you fighting so white Diablos with who
is that V Phoenix over there I thought
we were supposed to do that I can't
believe this then I wouldn't I would
never I would never monster cheat on you
I think promise yeah I appreciate that
so that I think the next one is the one
with like the five or six monsters in it
so that's cool all right
fast hunt do we want to capture them
that's a lot of traps we don't have to
bring traps yeah I've got two in my
inventory that I carry around I mean no
I mean yeah hmm you know let's let's do
it on the fly sure let's it's gonna take
it as good joob joob joined us what's up
dude no also a Droid akin nice if you
guys hunted the temperature and yet
yeah twice but that's that's that fights
counted I have not thought that tempered
carrying an ax it's so much tempered
fight so that actually it's a heck of a
fight like you need to have the the
Thunder mantle for it I imagine but yeah
it's a it's a fun fight though
I should probably have some stuff I
should let see some cool cool crafts
mm-hmm
you finished some bounties yeah I got
some bounty I should turn those in I
should check in the ecological Research
Center all right could all these
beautiful people and our hub hanging out
I mean if again if you guys can't get
into a hunt with us
definitely by all means like get amongst
yourselves
exactly I think we got to get about
people in here right right if you want
it yeah make sure dude you got a whole
group of people here to help do event
quests even if you're not able to do
with us I'm going to prepare to pose
yeah let me just get these bounties real
quick I can I'll grab it from down here
the wild spire bolero oh yeah I need to
uh mmm I may use a C L just recess but I
couldn't be doing anything there right
you're on this Oh
hunt - bird wyverns what we are doing
that that's that's calm and then capture
a faint why friend uh I think there's
something going on here so maybe we'll
find out and then ah bone piles favorite
type of field research get some of those
quality bones well that's a hard hard is
better than advanced right yes I believe
Marsala is
yes I'll grab that one hey black star
how's it going good to see you all right
post that quest and it I'm gonna go to
the first camp do it can use the voucher
oh yeah he's a fat one yeah see that's a
rank seven those are all high rank boys
all right should be up sweet which one
did you go to the first one first one
cool so I feel like when when you've got
this many monsters like it doesn't
matter too much where you start off
you're just gonna eventually
end up where we need to end up all right
we got a full crew here I like it
um I'm trying to think I'm gonna I'm
gonna go take a look at my my box make
sure I've got all my stuff got
everything you need
maybe I'll move it back over to my
switch axe looks like I really like okay
my longsword I've gotten back into it
but really I want to just want to I want
to let loose you know want to let it rip
let's see restock some stuff okay max
mega potions
next mix flash pods that's good I'll
throw in a shark trap that's it though I
only have a shock trap maybe I could
craft another trap actually no no I can
make a pitfall trap I think oh you're
getting your traps all set up yeah I'm
getting a couple traps so that we have
so we should have more than enough tranq
bombs if a couple I also need to make
some tranq bombs
I started excited like I had none so I
started setting those up at the
ecological Research Center gotcha
sweet magic items let's get let's get a
couple like a barrel bombs in there much
tranq bombs and my other trap I made
which is where are you okay yeah I think
I think I think I'm good I need
something here this is something that's
a little more sharp or do i okay yep I
am full on everything so B plus a blue
spine whatever I don't I don't need to
have that extra sharpness not when my
axe explodes actually let me quickly
make one more
fleshpot Kuroko a greatsword
I I wish that I was good at greatsword
but I haven't played with a greatsword
for a very long time I might ride
getting back into it but I'm like long
shorts which acts almost all day every
day unfortunately but maybe after a
little bit more practice I don't want to
embarrass myself too much right I'm
ready
honest on a stream with one I'm set up
I'm ready to go heck yeah
let's hit it I also mentioned something
about a meal voucher I didn't I don't
think any of us to use that I ate my
food too quickly I got too excited and
got mine before it it happened but
appreciate it anyway oh boy yeah yeah
dude it's Friday I keep forgetting that
these are at the end of the week I know
right even though I've done it a couple
of times at this point already oh it
still feels like a beginning of the week
thing to me and I forget just how kind
of tired I get you know but it's been a
busy week it has been next week's gonna
be real busy as well yeah yeah alright
what are we going for a first we got a
fair amount of stuff let's maybe go for
the the yaku all right he might be over
in the forest area yeah let's go check
that out
we'll see what we can find akari's in
here this game is dead on xbox I mean I
think it's sold really well in all
platforms I don't we don't play it on
xbox but I I don't think it's dead I
think it's dead I'm not really I know
the deal here with that community at
some point they had some connection
issues or something I was hearing about
but I think those have been fixed or
they're being fixed so that might be the
only thing to kind of look out for but I
feel like the player base is pretty
pretty good that's probably pretty solid
can't believe how much I fell in love
with this game right El Presidente Sam
it's it's really cool to have I say it
literally every show but I'm just really
happy that like a lot of people have
finally got a chance to try on Monster
Hunter I've gotten into it oh I found
the boy oh really I'm gonna go for him
there's a bear off that were your friend
to bear off - I believe so
we are you want you want to murder on
him really quick yeah let's do a murder
on him real quick right hook this bear
off here oh it's a tiny one is it how
you won Wow I mean nothing's gonna be
the same as the one during the request
right yeah it's huge
whoo okay I'm just gonna knock all my
friends around because I'm a horrible
person he's already running see he knows
what's up he's like ah man not why today
I was three days away from retirement I
missed I missed by a lot I went back
okay
man oh I'm gonna go for it it's the
dirtiest monster hunter boy aah
I hit him but do that oh no too big
mud mud I'm gonna say mud I think it's I
think it's mud I'm gonna pray it's mine
yeah I just I think I knocked you up in
the air no no I did that I did like a
slide my slide move
oh I almost said I was gonna avoid that
by by doing my my latch onto his face
but I guess I didn't Dan loading the
jitters don't kill the monsters they did
nothing wrong that is what my girlfriend
supposed to me every time I play this
game there's there's a little part of me
that feels bad every time just like what
are you doing
and I'm like don't worry I'm gonna
capture this one and then I like gonna
tail off like well could she could you
like do there like after you capture it
or suddenly you didn't need to cut the
tail off to capture it I'm like you you
are right we could have kept those for a
car but I do need these rare cards you
see it says in my monster manual that it
has a chance to drop a gem if I cut its
tail off yeah I remember playing the
earlier games wishing seers got more
attention I'm glad it finally is getting
its shine every amount of time exactly
it's it's a good feeling I love that I
can now talk to more people about
because it was an experience that isn't
like a lot of other games you know I I
hope this continues I last year was a
really good year for Japan I would you
like and in Monster Hunter act is a good
continuation of that trend and I hope it
continues to be honest because it's the
same
every time you do that I get so jealous
I think Japanese games are maybe some of
my favorites in terms of just like they
they kind of really go for it in terms
of originality and design yeah come on
it's I'm having a good two years more
people are finally playing yeah yeah
I've been playing Monster Hunter me and
Michael have been on that yaki citrate
and was like I actually mentioned she
goes really early like I go to like
where I was working before I'd be like
hey guys came out I got localized right
and feels like white isn't that like GTA
I like that GTA clone and you're all
actually not at all it's not that's what
I always thought it was but you know
that was kind of a it outwardly it looks
like a like a GT yeah that is a that is
a poor that came definitely suffered
from a poor simplification yeah or like
I mean I imagine the marketing of that
game they were like I don't know it's
like GTA but Japanese will market it
like that look at all even though that's
like really not what the game is at all
but it's so much more highly recommend
it to anyone if you haven't I mean can
you go bowling in actually yeah let's go
boy you play darts yes I believe so
karaoke I don't think you can do that
anything you can shoot it so you don't
they go nope that's that's what we got I
also don't think there's a real estate
management minigame actually I think in
Vice City there was the thing where you
could buy a home well you did the
chicken run your finances this is true
the chicken did not want any of my men
you know what my city +12 Yakuza boom do
we get like an actual chart kind of like
what what does Jacques I have over over
GG a and just lay it out
can you run an orphanage
no they would never do would never do
that no no they would never well what if
what if we ever got a GTA with like like
like a good boy protagonist what if that
have likes like a Kiryu style that's
just not in there yeah that is not rock
star style at all
they're all about that like satirical
you know American culture type stuff
like I don't think they would ever yeah
make a protagonist that is like just a
good boy but oh I like I don't want
anyone to think I don't like Jesus oh
yeah I'm not trying to lecture GT or
anything
I was like man kind of sounds like we're
beating down on GT know and love GTA
I've played that's true Blackstar I
don't think you can beat someone with a
bike yeah there you go another point for
Yakuza listen I sit here and swing
around like an idiot again oh no we
broke another part of them that's that's
the other thing they make breaks you
like they're more impactful in this game
and maybe that's the thing that's really
messed with me mm-hmm
click that screen shakes you hear like a
really yeah bass T kind of like oh [ __ ]
something happened what did I break off
of it this time
BAM got him know that we run away sweet
some said John Rochon was pretty good
John Marston is pretty good John
Marsten's definitely up there in like
top video game protagonists I mean that
game stories is phenomenal it's it's a
classic Cowboys hell but it's so good so
good see all right now the fun part who
we looking for this little boy what do
we got oh we probably find the
salamander boy over in the ponds oh yeah
that's a neat that's a good one head
over that way and see what else we can
stand
oh no I'm tracking the thing we just
killed that's not good at all
it's like it's over here look at these
old photos boo these old photographs
these footprints oh man where is I come
around this corner I'm gonna see them
just kind of hanging out also this is a
thing that I don't really do very much
in this game Oh were you gonna swing on
those bugs
yeah and just kind of like spider-man
you way acrost I need to use that a lot
more oh there we go he's right here
so go ahead car ease cars feeling it
feels really cool
swoop jumps on the way I hit it so hard
it flopped out of the water onto its
side awesome I don't really know how
that works but sure yo I'm not gonna
argue with physics Oh Harry yep sure
right right there oh my god whoa dang it
oh I hate the head I'm looking for a
wild ride
I don't wiggle into me
which that Mad Max team had gotten more
look yeah I think he might had a really
rough time yeah I didn't play it but I
know it got a lot of crap but I also
heard a lot of people say it actually
isn't as how many sad as people were
making to have to be yeah I had some
redeeming stuff to it it sounded like
the car stuff was good which is really
what you want yeah exactly especially in
a game like that say heart I think I
said your name right and if I didn't I
apologize I see you
I noticed you I'm glad you're here those
are waiting for Shenmue yeah I'm yeah
what's up with that curious how that
game is gonna turn out especially in
like a Wow a post like Yaquis our world
hosts Yakuza how is Shenmue gonna fare
yeah pretty much like the entirety of
Yakuza has happened I feel like within
Shenmue yeah
some /n new game so I haven't killed one
of these high rank yet like what are
they gonna do to like stand out right
yeah just me grab I've never played
Shenmue personally so I can't really
comment on it but everyone I know who's
tried to replay it spent like boy this
game is dated yeah there's a lot of
QuickTime events and stuff and not worry
about getting off topic that I feel like
oh yeah like Monster Hunter Fridays is
debt we're playing Monster Hunter
exactly you guys but I feel like
anything's kind of open for discussion
do we want to go Ratheon or Diablos
probably laughs all right wait any
kaizen zero down armors come back I
believe that's next week
I think it's next week and we'll be here
all dressed up as a Loy perfect it'll be
a fun time I'm actually really excited
about that one same we're all gonna have
to use bows and all bo bo boy bands
having a good time I hate to play that
horizon DLC I bought it over at the
holiday and I just haven't a chance
I just need to play horizon I feel good
game feel like I really enjoyed what I
played of it but I got like everyone
else got sidetracked by Zelda and I mean
that game like you know what hunting
down those big monsters it feels like a
monster ah yeah that those kind I think
what I was really into the most some
like Oh me and monster owners really far
away maybe I could play this to kind of
fill that void um I think the Ratheon
I'm gonna go to the nest although they
might not be who says he's height from
Shenmue but no faith that it's coming
out anytime soon yeah I mean they it's
one of those weird things where it's
like well technically it's supposed to
come out this year according to some
date from a while ago but the fact that
they haven't really said anything of
that game or showed anything in that
game makes me think it's probably not
coming out this year yeah oh wait no we
got the wrath you know on the map it's
over this way oh cool we don't even have
to have to worry about it I think the
game is trying to tell me to fight
Diablos
hold your horses game well we'll take
down Diablo Diablos in a bit loading
loading legit I want to save that one
for last make sure they they're the last
thing we see on our way out
I've already killed one of one of these
wrath ian's though I knew you're about
to do that waited big payout I get
tanked hit the slide perfect did you did
you actually get on you came home the
second I start sliding he turned his
tails right there oh that was perfect
beautiful that is set beautiful
beautiful playing a lot of Bayonetta
that's good yes I finally got my my code
for my first name to work so now I have
the the two box copies that I have that
the two box arts for I'm jealous so
that's that's pretty cool thing I was
gonna post a picture of it
Oh God so we don't do it when I get done
with the stream like oh man look at it
look at these boxes what I'm gonna do
I'm gonna cut all these poison cups I'm
gonna point I'm gonna get half of these
boys and cops because one of them's
already cut make it real hard for us all
to walk around yeah just landmine here
do thats that's how you do it you live
life on the edge
nope yep you just walked right into that
awesome
no I'm all stocked well been playing
monster hunter since day one amazing
game not I haven't been since day one
admittedly but I love the series a lot
yeah
but I'm I'm glad that even people who
have been playing since day one still
still like world so I know that we all
kind of had like a little bit of worry
about did I tell you that when I was
cleaning up the library I found a couple
copies of the original Monster Hunter
for ps2 you see a couple of copies a
couple yeah it's on - meaning like we
could we could we can play some Monster
Hunter oh gee what or if there is ever a
week where there's just nothing hanging
in Monster Hunter world like they decide
to take like the week off I'd be real
down to just pop in the original and
like nothing's happening no one no one
higher ups paying attention and we're
like yeah I know we're just lost artists
Fridays we're playing Monster Hunter and
we'll just not address the fact that
we're playing the first game at all
we'll just pretend like we're playing
world oh god I'd be down for that I'm
actually really curious I've never
played it so I've played a little bit of
it but we can land up okay thank you I
can get a land going I just cut off that
tail with my axe nice feeling really
good I moved oh and then there you go
so in flash spotted huh is this on the
switch no it's not but there is a game
called double cross that only came out
in Japan I'm a switch you could import
it technically I'm its region freeze
region free but you wouldn't be able to
play with other people I believe there's
there's a little bit of me that kind of
wants to import it like also you
wouldn't know it's yeah you don't have
to know Japanese also I'll just you see
the good thing about Monster Hunter 2 is
the use symbols for everything so you
can kind of like follow along if you if
you know enough about what you're doing
right oh I know what our Rathalos plate
looks like her
I know what this armor sell so that was
actually I really looked up footage of
the original monster and our our shock
that like the symbol for like the
potions the stuff is still the exact
same like yeah icon like oh wow like
they just kind of cleaned it up and read
room in HD but it's kind of this always
been the same same visual elements which
is actually pretty cool so the one thing
that I really really like that is the
constant is the little like little
drawings of each of the monsters to kind
of like tell you what's going on right
who are you gonna hunt on this hunt oh
it's all these little monsters kept like
in a small block and I'm really into
that all right here we go monster boss
boy let's do it high rank Diablos yowzer
you know Rooney's I should so far though
this is actually not been that bad um it
only had to use a heal once I'm only now
carving oh that's good my blade
you gotta get the sharpness at some
point uh but better with people you mean
more difficult it depends on who you're
playing with and I feel like I mean it
it technically is more difficult because
they do up the difficulty but yeah III
still kind of prefer playing with with
other people because you get that like
oh man I just I just knocked him over
everyone get over here quick put to put
up a put up a barrel blow him up like
yeah kind of be able to like yell and
get excited about hunting on a thing
with your friends and then also when you
mess up and you got to kind of share the
defeat because you all got carted three
times I'm kind of I'm kind of down with
that it's a good time
let me get my a my sharpen on such
monster manners you played every game in
Monster Hunter when you solo it's so
much more fun I do kind of prefer the
solo life because I don't have to depend
on anyone else but right it's really
really fun to play with other people I
feel like that's also because it's the
way that I kind of got brought into it
was a bunch of my friends being like hey
yo get in those Monster Hunter Train and
I was like all right I don't know where
we're going but I'm in and I kind of
like learned that way I guess no I like
it I like it I like it either way that's
a good flash house waiting I like it
that tail
I'm all of all about the tail business
right now and then I just got hit by the
tail
perfect that's that's the what I'm
looking for
no oh that was not what I wanted I don't
want to die please don't die please
don't die okay good
is the other fun thing about co-op is
when you're doing stuff like this kind
of monster you're like oh cool you just
tracked him for a sec yeah I need to do
a thing I need to try to avoid dying
completely and embarrassing myself so I
totally didn't realize that my stamina
drop until now look I timed that way
wrong okay okay I can maybe get a slide
now which acts are using this taki stuck
nice this is the basil goose
basil basil geese beetlejuice
the expo Deacs you get fur for fighting
the beef farmer JL the first thing of
the day goes to you congratulations yeah
it's been an honor
hey just over to a new campsite whoa
gratz oh you you must not have all the
other camps I don't I don't have them
all I'm just not bothered to do it like
I probably could just like quickly knock
it out and like no but like 20 minutes
ago when we were doing our guide for it
I was like I'll just look it up and grab
him really quickly there was only like
four left that I hadn't grabbed before
then they give a lot to you through the
through the actual story but yeah then
the other ones who get through it's easy
to get there multiplayer like this
scenario exactly you die and you wake up
one one morning inside of a place you
didn't know existed I can't really see
what's happening and I'm very afraid I
feel bad about dying though because it
means our rewards got reduced that's we
almost made it with no deaths I mean if
we're gonna die on any person
was gonna be the a yeah that's true oh
okay we need to move we need to move I
think they're I think they're oh okay I
don't know I was getting nervous it's
okay it's all right
ooh his long-sword up - yeah what's not
how long we're gonna be on well we're
gonna do the final event after this so
at least another 30 minutes yeah
it all kind of kind of depends I guess I
mean how how everything unfolds I know
if we want to get that other stab at
black Diablos - or maybe it depends how
long the other one goes yeah as much as
I'd love to be here all day but I stream
Monster Hunter all day I do have other
things stream Worcester Hunter old de
Sade show them I need to take care of
before the meantime yep
that's what I said uh take gave the okay
everything's good to go an eight-hour
Monster Hunter stream right now on the
real life so really I really like the
idea of playing the first Monster Hunter
like a lot
I like that tail yeah we did it it's in
the refrigerator I knew it the whole
time he says what other things you gotta
get as history of us together and you
got got some cool got some other videos
yeah contrary to popular belief I don't
just play Monster Hunter
dang here at work whereas I got I got
cool pictures yeah yeah I paid money for
these
let me spam them sweet also I like I
like this one I should just man
boy ice on it boy boy that's all I
imagine it says I should probably put
that as the text for it
is that a UH was that what's-her-name
from Street Fighter yeah there's a BuChE
BuChE yeah
rainbow mica and there's some other ones
in there but they don't matter says he
needs more history Alice well don't
worry man you'll get one tomorrow
buckle-up gives you it over the UK it's
got a good history of before yeah ooh
hello
what is this always in Creole yeah would
you get decoration that enhances the the
poison functionality skill Oh dragon
jewel let's make a play jewel the poison
weapon my hunter rank went up 54 now
more optional quests are available I'm a
survival expert and an ailment master
and a slinger sniper who I got a
miniature crown your ants oh no black
black Diablos Azure Rathalos and double
Joe in an arena imagine I don't want to
because that's that's a straight-up
nightmare if you could fight tempered
versions of them in an arena you know
what throat flippin basil goose in there
too massive messing up real bad you just
wouldn't be even get a chance to breathe
yeah goob I don't know I'm always
worried the history of swear I'm not
sure if I like which is a surprise but
also it's like I mean I could just say
really matter I feel like I've already
kept it enough of a mystery mate I just
want to say what it is this week but I
don't know it's nothing really wrong
with just saying what it is that's fair
it yes
what's your gear set you're using up the
switch axe I'm using the loader Garen
set just because I like the sharpness
and affinity bonuses you get from it
it's definitely not the best thing if I
wanted to boost the explosion damage for
the switch X but it kind of negates some
of the negatives of it and also kind of
enhances the stuff I've got the belt
from there you got a 2 it gives you a
little bit of an attack boost but nice
nice
yeah it's I'm just messing around with
sets and trying to like see what I can I
can mess around with it's kind of kind
of cool yes
alright dude yeah you ready yeah I'm
ready I don't think we'll ever be ready
but here we go either way before you
post it just let me yeah
oh no I'm what you getting cuz we're
gonna stare at this and wanna be like
yep snow and cherry blossoms in the
coral islands so they're probably
actually you know what I have done pods
so we can at least try to get them
separated I have some as well that's
that's a very important thing we're
gonna need to do I feel like we should
fight the lag Jana first I'm gonna say
yeah let's try that all right post it
alright I'm ready I'm ready let's do
this do it - into fashion to do sets go
to the northeast camp yeah yeah oh yeah
that's that's very close to it uh you
know what this is how oh so if you want
it absolutely no voucher aid fashion
hunter is a very real thing absolutely I
understand that what it says my rank
isn't high enough oh my god how did this
happen well dude you'll just have to I
guess I'll just have to go on without me
then Ben I can't do this I can't I can't
believe I'll be cheering you from the
sidelines
alright I guess you can join up with
someone else and kind of do a quest with
them and we'll we'll take it from me
I'll watch I'll commentate
I'm oh man I'll work on my my
shoutcasting sounds like a plan I'm into
it wow I'm really no hind effort and
that's the first time that's happened I
think it's because it's it's a temper
deal and I actually haven't really done
much tempered stuff so let me probably
actually what it is oh that's actually a
really I should throw together the Basel
goose armor just because of I think it
gives you earplugs and it also boosts
your explosion damage I have some
good-looking people in here all right
cool armor and then you got me looking
like an actual Punk a real scrub you
want actually hold on I'm going to so
I'm probably how do I need to do that to
it I'm gonna change back to a sword and
you know it it's probably cuz I never
beat those two bow so goose tempered
ones that might be it a weekend
I'm sure you could actually probably
throw together a thing for that if you
really I'm gonna try and throw the thing
together hey you keep doing your thing
cuz that's what the people have come for
yeah yeah but I'm gonna set up mine so
people in there if you want to join me
for my thing fight some double basil
geese they're here for you
bang bagel gooses so I'll set up a thing
if people want to join me for that watch
you're gonna get a tote yourself now
wants to do it again no I'm oh there you
go Blackstar here Thank You Black Star
built building up that crew alright we
have the ability will be able to switch
what we'll focus mainly on yours but we
can maybe there's a lull whole switch
over to mine everything Oh God
dropped right in on one of these these
boys toes of course I did
I'm gonna just I'm gonna try to meet up
with my pals
oh man so I found the pink or a thean if
anyone's curious perfect yeah
Oh someone's saying I need to fight
these two battle boys those good ol boys
well that do Blackstar I'm gonna be
honest he looks like somebody out of a
one-piece
oh yes real good now I'm gonna show that
look at that look at that dude
he is looking awesome see if you guys
want to fight the wrath you in there I
guess there are out this way and back to
Ben all right cool
all right guys hey everyone get all set
up for mine Phoenix will be back next
time I look forward to it oh they're
flying away perfect I think we've got to
go up for a leg oh thanks for joining us
dude
appreciate it
[Music]
so in the chest there's no one answer to
my question does any remember the
deviljho glitch in Monster Hunter Tri
did you play try I try was the one that
I got in on I don't remember any
glitches though I guess maybe that's cuz
I was just oblivious to anything that
was happening someone else guys saying
the same thing that I remember I was
just like yeah man good monster hunts
this is really rad I got a fight a thing
underwater what that sounds pretty cool
it would be if you could control her
you're going oh oh boy all right I guess
we're fighting this guy first
nope
right
oh boy Ben I'm feeling this I feel like
mine's gonna be tougher than yours
because that fight was not a joke that
the battle boys are like higher tier I
feel like then I feel anything like well
maybe the no no I feel like they are
there definitely are yeah they're
definitely higher tier and annoying like
oh my god yeah okay you're okay
whoo oh my god
I mean yes it's nice to meet you but
that's not what I wanted to do oh yeah
I'm knocked down get in there get in
there
cool we've already found one it's kid
and then you got to worry about the
second one showing up yeah in the middle
not into that at all all right well
let's hop down here on this ledge on
well they're flying away the game like
put me on a Ledge and okay there we go
chase them down
I was a great shot
somebody says he's a bow on the back of
boys sue oh yeah that so the person that
actually carried me through it when I
did it cuz I made with a random group of
people was a person with a heavy bow gun
and they just ran the whole fight and I
was like well this is nice yeah weird to
my god uh let's see
looks like we got ya there's someone
with a bow somebody with a looks like a
switch axe and then me and Aaron here
are using some dual blades there we go
keep that monster mount
oh I immediately fainted Wow that
classic big goose Wow
sorry I got I'd just like hopped in and
immediately died wow wow wow wow limit
to my death yeah sorry about that boys
see an arena there's a quest where you
fight deviljho
or two judges at the same time the
glitch was if you put one to sleep the
other one would you kill the other one
it was whoa what that wasn't a glitching
what if that was intentional
dude we're murdering this thing oh yeah
you guys seem like you're having a
better time all right well the - oh my
god bagger boys I've now met each other
so Claire they're together just hanging
out chilling yeah yeah why didn't I just
die like so I mean I guess I just wasn't
a bad spot we're doing it I'm gonna let
these boys carry me through this to be
honest that's that's totally fair I'm
feeling I'm feeling much better about
this we've got a real solid crew going
on
which one already Phil ha you guys got
some rare stuff out of here alright and
the leg Jana is already on our map up
over this way and get this going and
we'll climb all this musics intense too
yeah flip in their theme is very very
good and also frightening pop these mega
nutrients
[Music]
it's true GameSpot is not gamestop
although a lot of the time even we
sometimes we slip up and say it which is
funny like oh man I love working at
Gamestop I mean dude there are a lot of
people actually when I got this job
they're like wait you're moving across
the country for working Damon stop was
it like I'm like a high rank corporate
position wage senior game advisor it's
very serious
oh they're all the way at the top
all right hopping up that health booster
over here there we go this is where you
you actually get to use the the kind of
spider-man web swing stuff a lot oh come
on I feel very helpless with just some
dual blades against these boys they're
not yeah it's really weird and Master
Hunter to like cuz like the the
aesthetic for master honor is big
weapons and big monsters and then we got
like some some kind of like slightly
bigger knives
then what knives would normally be it
kind of kind of throws me off a bit but
I'm into it though that's why I made the
I made the explosion axes I really like
the axes okay okay no no stun no stun no
stun no stun come on come on
damn I'm gonna drop a health booster
back over here just in case I don't you
don't we don't need it right now first
save but I'm just gonna do it
oh god there's material so get something
out of this yikes
okay well that guy's got good checks or
I start charge blade do charge blades
are the thing I said yeah Diablos charge
bullied too nice it's not like sick oh
we lost Blackstar this is like the least
my least favorite place to be fighting
this thing right now actually tonight
okay all right all right
and then I'll fall down right on the ice
just like I planned all right sweetie
got some material how's your fight going
you know we're fighting them in this
really small area not my my favorite
place to be eaten one we're doing it
though all right
this this crew is is here too it's a
play for sure I should do that blight I
would but I feel like if I if I stay
wrapped up in the cold it helps me
understand the boss right now you know
when with their elements I am them
they're me the one that kind of deal
yikes
it's gonna try to run away it's gonna
definitely run away never mind I thought
I could latch on to him or something you
know I was wrong again I feel bad I
don't like don't want to fight these
boys because I'm just gonna instantly
get hit and die I feel like there's no
shame in playing it safe they want to
have any any poop to throw Oh chase one
of them off I did now I guess I forgot
about that
oh I missed it yet oh but this is this
is the best place to fight though
because it's all Kent like this hold
down Hill area just kind of get those
sweet jumps get my affinity sliding or
little fly away and I won't be able to
do it anymore
come back down come down here and face
me fight me
i ragazzi good good girl tail hit
[Music]
mmm nice I just saw that yeah I like
that
the unsheath hit that you can do oh good
one of them left I'm gonna drop another
health booster back over here at the top
of the hill kiss anyone anyone needs it
Oh from downtown
take them out it's when you manage to
clip the the edge of their wing like
that
oh I forgot some hair and stones got the
Karen bill blades like no way Gopal's
yeah so we'll throw together
oh he's leaving dang yowzer okay that
wasn't as bad as I thought it would be
dang good hunt my dudes you did it we
did it that was that was I think we've
all grown together hi do we want to swap
over to mine
oh yeah definitely all right there you
go and check up on this this bagel goose
nonsense
oh boy I'm not I'm not stoked about this
dude it's it's not a fight to be stoked
about where did those vines come from
they're uh they're the what are they
called the the not cats the raised
Malkin's growl grab whatever they are
they're the cats that are like native to
whatever the area is you're in if you
become friends with them enough they'll
like try to latch on and low drag that's
the yeah that's the wrong one okay any
of you get away from this one I was like
how come no one else is here they're all
fighting the other one which we were
close to the killing in fact I think
they killed that one pins and kill them
no they calo real captain dude you're
gonna get your stuff done too
hopefully we we do only have one more
three five I believe okay this is Logan
oh we we all showed up to that one too
good good rewards cool I mean I have to
I don't have to go get a cart the carve
on that one since I captured it yeah
has anyone seen the new G rank do you'll
see there I haven't seen anything I
heard anything if this is new and I
don't know yeah
because as far as I know they haven't
talked to they haven't mentioned
anything about that but I want G rank so
badly
so do you captured her what what is this
game about so the idea behind monster
hunter is
I'm not I'm I'm not gonna be a dick and
just books mostly just haunt monsters I
so you kind of it's all about a loop
basically where you go you come into
town they give you a quest to go and
hunt something that's like causing
trouble and you take parts from that
monster that you fight and you craft new
better gear to go and fight new bigger
badder monsters and it's just a constant
loop of getting better while you're
fighting new things basically and you
can choose to either cut it down and
actually kill it which oh my god
that was so close that would have been
awesome so you can you can kill it or
you can capture it and capturing it
gives you a better chance at getting
different loot or better loot from it so
you get kind of an option if you don't
want to be like really mean doing murder
you'll notice I'm just running away a
lot is because I'm kind of a little
underpowered for this and I just don't
want to die so I'm kind of being a bit
of a wimp
the red hue pulsing is the heartbeat so
that's that's the I guess that's more
like a threat meter but it tells you
that you're engaged with the monster and
they're actually coming after you the
heartbeat is down sort of like up on the
bottom next to the little icon next to
the mini-map you can kind of see it
going but oh yeah a monster randomly
assigned stuff so these guys there's
kind of a set order they do a good job
of kind of like especially in this game
because it's the first time they have
monsters fighting monsters well not the
first time it's it's it's a big hook of
this one I guess you can have multiple
monsters on a map at a time right but
they'll show you like here's the great
jag wrists they're kind of like a medium
sized monster that's whatever and then
later on they'll build - like here's
engine ass it's a giant flame spewing
t-rex that just ate the Jaguars that you
finished hunting a while ago so they
kind of use monsters to kind of step you
up to bigger more and
once so there is kind of a set path for
it you'll throw that poker ball is what
what ad can I can see is telling you I
think I said your name correctly yeah
story you kind of just go through the
story and as you go you get bigger and
badder monsters someone saying Capcom's
teasing a new quest you want to read
that while I'm I can't really do long
it's a new quest that will make
obtaining rare items easier revealed it
will be easy and accessible true or for
those who are just starting the game and
want to be able to find something to get
in and like enjoy I guess so that's
that's good
I'm down for more accessible monster
honor basically if we can get more
people to play and feel good about what
they're doing that's that's good as long
as I still have the accessibility of
going and playing higher rank stuff I'm
totally into that but yeah
people think it's G rank yeah okay so
they actually haven't said what it is
people are suspecting definitely
something to keep an eye on though I've
oh you're like they can't not add G rank
at this point because of how popular
this game is right also I wouldn't be
surprised if we got another monster
teaser sometime soon I imagine that'll
be after deviljho though right yeah I I
just want gore Magali I'm a gormogon to
come back this is kind of my one of my
favorite monsters besides Rathalos but
we're always gonna have rathalos grandpa
theme is so awesome folks pretty iconic
enough to yeah right here visually this
game looks so awesome the variety of
monsters is something of great
imagination the designs of the monsters
in the gear is so crazy to me every time
because I don't know how they know ah we
did we lost it's okay you know Zarin who
got hit no worries guys I appreciate you
even doing that so you want to want to
do you want to do another stab at that
but I can join you this time sure why we
do that
we even see the whole fight for that
yeah and one with that well we'll end
with you getting your your rank on lock
for a higher higher level Oh point your
first tempered monster grats on your
trophy thank you
I'll brekkie else would be good uh uh
actually papa back over to yours because
I think my game audio is kind of low
I don't know why but I think here's a
little I think I think mines when we
have everything like leveled with yeah
like mines in there but it's just really
quiet for some reason oh all the other
monsters defeats game is it's true this
game does have the least of all the
monsters and that's probably because
they had to actually remake all the
assets like if you're talking about like
like cross or right or for or any of
them like they could literally just
transfer the monsters over into the new
game and do some small tweaks to make
them work but here they had to redo all
of it I got some stuff I can get oh you
actually have to put the quest up i
right sorry yeah hold on a sec no no
rush we're good does the game teach you
decently enough in how to play it so is
great as Monster Hunter is it doesn't do
a great job of onboarding at all in that
straight-up old games wouldn't have any
tutorial at all I feel like this one
does kind of a better job of easing you
into it but you definitely if you don't
know how to do like combos and stuff
going into the training areas is a good
option
alright I'm gonna post it is it yeah
it's an assigned one the other good
thing is there are a lot of really good
just resources available like you find
like a Rex or gaijin hunter they all
have fantastic guides on every weapon in
every sort of instance of everything in
the game if you ever wanna figure out
about it covered extensively like I
think dodging hunters like weapon
tutorial videos are like 40 minutes long
he tells you literally everything
you need to know so there are resources
out there if you want to get like really
deep into it but if you want to just
jump in I feel like this game does a
really good job of getting in you're
getting that that angry pickle coming up
I'm real excited for that flippin
Devil Joe's gonna be a real real fun
time off opens an ogres gonna be a good
time to okay feeling equipment-wise
pretty good it's the boss did you feel
it the finality of today yeah all right
how ready I am also ready standby for
departure oh we're gonna mess up these
bagel geese hopefully we can do it are
they adding new monsters to these games
so we know they're adding deviljho at
some point so they're they're working on
DLC and it's all free which is good what
are you guys trying to farm for so right
now we've we finished all the event
quests and right at the moment we are
going to do the double tempered bagel
goose fight so John Buchan can finish it
see where his hunter rank goes somebody
asked how many weapons there are 14 yeah
there are 14 different weapons as much
as you'd like to kind of master all of
them it takes a lot of time and
dedication like I've been trying to
build up multiple weapons of multiple
types so I can at least try to vary it
up but in the end I always fall back on
my switch axe or my longsword right same
but yeah so many questions it's it's a
series that's new to a lot of people so
uh totally fine I I'm happy to try it
and help out as much as I can
those no need to feel sorry about it
either it's totally totally legitimate
yeah I'm just waiting on Fenrir here
should you start playing you know what
heading into the weekend getting
yourself a monster honor like purchase
set up you're gonna have a good time and
if you can also convince your friends to
get it playing multiplayer is a blast
though it's kind of wonky in this one
who thinks they'll add a new area to
explore and hunt possibly I feel like
we're really missing a frozen area yeah
we're like a water area water area would
be kind of cool well they they kind of
have like the thing about the coral
highlands is it's like it's under water
but it's not really right we might be
able to just go we'll just go with a
diamond I did because we can we can eat
when we're there if they haven't eaten
yet and there's also an item box mhm
just to just to keep the show flowing
I'm sorry I interrupted you while you
were totally sorry if you weren't 100%
ready yet but we gotta get those going
as much as I want people to sit here and
stare at my character and his armor and
I appreciate it really cool beard yeah
we leaving my wife high and dry if I get
this game I don't know if want to make
her a Master Hunter Widow Oh God uh get
her a copy of the game as well hunt
together mmm how's that guy just rip
didn't join us
I'm dang so so there's a spot open if
it's not open it wants to join sad a
friend rare but for this bagel goose
adventure to take a little take a little
too long I'm going to equip my dung pods
right off the bat because I am not about
to whoa forgot about the fact that I've
got some some stuff in my inventory oh
my empty that out really quick so I
didn't get that captured ones stuff at
all did I I don't think so yeah I did
get them a couple materials that fell at
least which is good that's there yeah oh
and definitely fill all that up Oh found
one
cool Dell Way has joined us they're
there with me when we were doing the
quest no good guys buying us a second
Xbox one believe me if I could I would
who I'd love to help you up but I I
can't even have a second Xbox one so
we've got this one in front of us I
don't see the second one we can I saw
just go after this one
heck yeah so I've hunted bagel geese and
pheromones right because you got some
really sick some sick stuff because I
was way into the exploding affinity
stuff for a while but it has been bit so
I'm gonna be a little rusty that's okay
I have very little experience fighting
this guy I'm gonna put a healing thing
down over here
[Music]
no come back here
I'm just a little too slow oh there's
the other one
cool all right I'm gonna try to get it
out of here get away from me no oh all
right I was kidding me I'd swipe me no
no no no no there we go
it's done is you left yep back down to
just the one Suites that's what I want
good thing about fighting them here too
is the fact that if we need to get more
health potions we're good yeah
unfortunately got a faint it's all good
my dude this is this is not a joke of a
fight I'm still getting getting real
messed up no no no stay over there did
it the victor shoot the glass nose my
bad I've seen that's uh I don't even
know how to say your name yes al I'll
say al no worries dude ain't no thing
bump-bump
[Music]
oh shoot that was dumb of me I just love
how their theme sounds like it's like a
like a like a cartoon villain I'm gonna
die it's gonna be me it's gonna be me
you can't leave
come on come on turn around get up
stop hey they're leavin leaving no I was
gonna flash pot him out of this yeah I
was trying to do it to you but couldn't
get a good angle it's too slow all man
Master Hunter and VR it might be too
much VR master honor yeah I'd play it
though I'd give it go yo just
head-butted his friend
okay which one do we want we want the
one flying right now I think so yeah
there we go
the other ones already running away
perfect give this back
whoever's on those those dumb pods
killing it
oh my goodness
the way he's done trap already oh my god
this is we gotta traps
are we trying to I don't think I don't
think we've got it down yeah we don't
have it down of that but it's very least
get some good hits on it I'm gonna set
up a health minister good call was run
right in front of you guys you're trying
to shoot your bow I just all I can he's
glowing and I don't want to get near him
yeah I'm not a big fan of blowing either
no bummer just dropping him on the side
of the wall oh shoot Wow whoa around the
sides towards you made a sharp turn into
me I really thought that they were gonna
like try to come back I all backup ends
and do a heel
all right it's Mike's
all these tiny tiny tiny dinosaurs we
got here
I'm not even getting like I'm not
getting all the hits I want I need more
hits just the hits
here we go again I'm gonna get him on he
comes back someone says they saw
somebody with a hunter rank of nine nine
nine I believe it there are people who
have been playing this game literally
non-stop since it came out that is and
crazy while I admire that I and there I
go my dad I thought that I died no that
was me I thought I god no worries okay
we can we can get it yeah unfortunately
uh we're out of time for the stream
which is a bummer didn't didn't get a
beat him but we gotta beat all the event
quest the shroom we finished all the
event quests and that last one was was a
real good time was a good bonus yeah so
thank you everybody for joining us for
Monster Hunter Fridays yeah we were
gonna be back we stream every every
weekday at 11:00 I also think there
might be another stream happening later
today at two possibly may possibly stay
tuned for that but yeah come come back
around 2:00 for that and yeah we'll be
back next week
I'm tryin think if there's anything cool
I want a pimp as I said early in this
gym we got a history of that Dave do it
over the UK did it's coming up tomorrow
and then we're gonna have a lot of other
cool stuff throughout the week so stay
tuned for that and thanks for watching
guys yeah see you next time have a good
weekend